So, let's take a closer
look at this command.
Print f is a shock command for
printing formatted strings.
If I run it on its own,
it just prints out what I've put here,
which is an HTTP request.
You can Printf anything like this,
it's kind of like echo, but
it's a little smarter.
You can do things like
turn into a line break.
Whereas echo would just print
out the \n's by themselves.
And nc stands for
net cat nd it's a handy tool for
mentally talking to internet services.
Here I'm giving a command that will
connect to the Wikipedia web server but
nc doesn't know anything about HTTP
in particular instead of Wikipedia.
I can use it to say hello to
the local host SSH server on port 22.
I can't speak SSH personally but
I can see what it says.
Or we could use it to say hello to
an email server such as Gmail's.
We get a little greeting
here from google.com SMTP,
which is the email protocol.
So we'll be using and see your netcat as
a sort of network Swiss army knife to
connect to various servers.
And later even to act
as a server itself.
Now let's take another look
at this here in the middle.
The vertical bar here is a pipe.
It's the standard UNIX way to say.
Take the output of this program and feed
it in as the input of that program So
we're taking the output of printf, which
is a string that forms an HTTP request
and we're using that as the input to nc.
Nc picks that input and sends it
over the network to the address and
port that we tell it to and
displays the output.